hey guys uh complex con a couple weeks
ago my homie ASAP ferg and I were gonna
do an askgaryvee he got caught up on
some business so what you're about to
watch is be improving a keynote and a
Q&A session when I was going into the
mindset of doing an askgaryvee hope you
enjoy it a lot of culture talk a lot of
attention talk a some really solid Q&A
at the end have a great holiday season
hope you're enjoying your Thanksgiving
weekend check it check it out how are
you guys good so obviously I had to flip
my schedule and the talk that I was
going to give from five to six is what
I'm gonna do now and me and further
we're gonna do askgaryvee later and
today whenever the [ __ ] he wakes up so
so listen I want to take full advantage
of having this much time and this
intimate of an audience so my plan is to
kind of maybe spit a couple of thoughts
that I think could bring some value I'm
also gonna be empathetic to know the
fact that most of you have some context
on me so I don't want to repeat [ __ ]
that I think you guys already know in
this stage of like sharing thoughts all
the time and what have you so I'll I'll
talk for about five minutes and then
honestly I'd love to go into Q&A and so
um because I think it's the best
opportunity for me to answer the
question so many of you have that I
can't answer sometimes in a DM or email
or things of that nature so I think um
the thing that I would want to talk
about here at complex con is that I've
been here for about an hour I wasn't
here yesterday and it's there's three or
four things racing through my head and
on first taste number one holy [ __ ] this
is exactly like the baseball card shows
that I grew up in back in a day so just
watching all those kids in line for
sneakers and the other swag trying to
like get a limited edition stuff flip it
make that dollar I just I mean there
might not be a more interesting show for
me to come to given that it's really so
close to my true essence it's just 25
years later so that that really stands
out and the entrepreneurial vibe and
that community to me is really
intriguing and just watching obviously
main differences this [ __ ] as a hell of
a lot cooler than baseball cards were so
watching it kind of crash into cool
culture and collecting entrepreneur
spirit hustler mentality it's just super
interesting for me never ever thought in
a million years that 20-year olds that
had this kind of swag would think I was
cool never really wrap my head around
entrepreneurship being put on it
cultural pedestal the way it is now but
I've got to be very honest it makes me
super happy it makes me super happy that
working hard and trying to achieve
something for you and your family is
something that people now think is cool
in the same way of being an athlete or a
rapper or an artist of some sort so to
me this is an incredible time the
Internet has created so much opportunity
the fact that so many people rolling
down they're coming from such humble
beginnings and they've got a couple of
pins with their business card on it or a
t-shirt that they pressed last week just
seeing that kind of grind is super
expiring to be very honest with you I
think the thing that I trade on and the
thing that makes me so confident about
how this all plays out for me is I am
far more attracted to the idea of let's
go right now to a printing press and
make some [ __ ] and set up a booth in the
corner and nobody knows who the [ __ ] we
are and try to sell something for 10
bucks then I am with the thought of like
I didn't go out last night right my dear
like 700 DMS of like yo this club in
this table and this spot and these
people and and it's just so interesting
to me like what draws me in and I know
that all the stuff that I got hit up
about last night is what draws a lot of
people in especially the young men in
the audience I get it but my hope is
that they get tricked along the way and
fall in love with the process not the
treasures that come along with it that
they fall in love with that intoxicating
feeling to wake up and feel purposeful
about something that's some [ __ ] that
went through their head one day that
motivated them they pasted it on a
t-shirt and I got going and it took off
and so I think it's an incredible time I
think the undercurrent of negativity in
society is is feeding it even more I
think it's the oxygen I like the idea of
people finally wrapping their head
around
that nobody's gonna do it for them not
their parents not their teachers not the
government nobody you know this morning
I posted nobody owes you [ __ ] on
Instagram and just kind of watched
everybody react to it and excited me
because it's something I've been saying
on social media for ten years and for
the first time the comments cuz you know
one thing for all the young kids in here
I would give you a huge piece of advice
spend a hell of a lot less time worrying
about how many likes and how many views
you get and start spending a hell of a
lot more time reading every [ __ ] word
somebody replies to a piece of content
you put out and more importantly then
take the time to maybe engage with it
[ __ ] will go in the right direction
anyway after 10 years on Twitter [ __ ]
let me go way back on MySpace and
Twitter and YouTube and Facebook and on
and on and on I would honestly tell you
this morning the way the community
responded to nobody owes you [ __ ] is
probably the most excited I've ever been
because over the last 10 years
everybody's jumping in and just coming
up with [ __ ] excuses but yeah but
yeah but this guy was me thirty bucks or
you know just funny different [ __ ] this
was the most collective like I agree
[ __ ] it and and that has been my calling
card the reason I get to sit here the
reason I get to go downstairs and have
this collaboration k-swiss the reason
I'm gonna achieve all my goals in life
most importantly impacting people in a
way that builds my legacy the good I'm
trying to give you a selfish you know
everybody's giving me loved with down
stairs I'm selfish I need that love I
you know I feed off the admiration in
your eyes that is what I'm trying to
achieve all the treasures and all the
things that come along with this I got
that a long time ago I thought I made it
when I made 100k 100k a year was my
barometer at 1516 I was like when I get
100k I wanted to buy the Jets but like
for some reason 100k was like right and
so we sent an incredible time we sent an
incredible time and if you're sitting
here with me right now at this kind of
event with me with this vibe well then
you're 99% of ahead of everybody else I
mean it like if I could just get people
to understand the perspective the fact
that you understand this culture the
fact that you have that undertone of
entrepreneurship and hunger and dry
if you were legitimately ahead of 99
percent the fact that this is Sunday
morning and it's early and I know we got
an hour back last night but it's still
[ __ ] early in a world where a lot of
people are just laying in bed right now
a lot in a world where three years ago
you were laying in bed to me that's
exciting and so this audience and this
these this convention center inspires me
and I'm just flattered I can spire back
and so let's let's talk about another
thing and then we'll open it up for Q&A
um you guys hear this for me but I'm
gonna keep pounding it because I never
want to ever let you waver from it it's
just about attention right attention is
the game like what you whatever you're
trying to achieve if you're trying to
raise money for a non-profit if you're
just trying to help your mom out at home
with another hundred bucks each month or
if you're trying to go for it all right
yachts and planes materialistically or
all-time legacy it's all gonna be the
same game can you understand where
people are paying attention that is
underpriced I understand that you guys
understand that intuitively it's why
you're sitting here the underpriced
attention in our society is on YouTube
it's on snapchat and right now more than
ever it's on Instagram right and so once
you understand that and again you take
it for granted what you don't understand
as I look at these young pretty faces is
it comes natural to you to understand
where everybody's trading and spending
time but the world isn't acting on that
my friends if the biggest companies in
the world understood what was actually
happening Nike and Adidas those [ __ ]
downstairs they'd be spending 70% of
their money on Instagram and snapchat
and YouTube and it's not even close
they'd be dropping product on everybody
just for the free exposure of your 7,000
fans cuz it'd be worth it so please do
not get it twisted do not get confused
you were ahead of the game theoretically
strategically now what you got to figure
out is two core things that everybody
[ __ ] up first of all the [ __ ] you put
out on those places needs to be for
people not for yourself the [ __ ] that
you put out on these platforms everybody
self-promoting everybody's trying to get
more followers everybody's trying to
sell something the reason I wrote Jab
Jab Jab right hook was trying to make a
very clear picture for you like give
give give and then ask if you pay close
attention who's winning that doesn't
have some disproportionate advantage
like they're already ridiculously famous
and or they're so [ __ ] attractive you
can't stop looking you know as long as
they don't have those two things if you
look at everybody else who's winning
they're giving in their content they're
giving in their content and they
understand let me give you something
small because I know you guys pay
attention why did I put that red bar at
the bottom of my videos cuz I'm testing
[ __ ] I'm trying to figure out how to
bring value like I learned you know when
you know I don't know how nerdy you guys
get but like medium how many people know
medium the blog post just the platform
cool you know what they did that [ __ ]
like blew my mind they told you how long
the article was to read it's kept like
three four years ago right you've
started seeing in other places I do it
on my blog because of it it says
three-minute read two-minute read
four-minute read it was crazy it seems
so simple but it was so valuable because
time is the most valuable thing and so
I'm always trying new things if I can
recommend anything for you one thing
that I've noticed is that everybody gets
into the same patterns with their
content look if you're a good
photographer you're just taking fly-ass
photos and it might be the skyline or
the beach or a piece of [ __ ] fruit
but it's the same fly ass photo right if
you look at my account right now I'm
mixing it up it's my normal [ __ ] like
the motivational [ __ ] that I could get
excited about it's the video clips that
I get excited about but I'm trying to
integrate more pictures to now like
you've got to break up your cadence cuz
you never know and then more importantly
within it you need to try [ __ ] and so
the red bar is just trying [ __ ] because
I knew that you'd know how long the
video was or and you know it like mean
videos the white borders and the white
look like somebody like I love when I
say this and be like oh [ __ ] that's true
somebody did that first there's some
persons like [ __ ] it this is how I'm
going to put out the video right or the
picture like there is a human that did
that first
I implore you to strive to be more
creative with your content and be the
first to do it this way or that way
because
god forbid aka please God if it pops you
can trade just on that legacy like if I
was walking right now it's like yo yo
I'm the dude that came up with the you
know I'm the girl that came up with the
meme I'd be like oh [ __ ] let's hang like
how'd you do like it's unbelievable and
to me it all comes down to the context
of all this which is this is just all
culture and what's amazing about culture
right now is it could come from any
angle I'm old
at 42 growing up with hip hop the way I
did you had to be hard like like if you
go really some of you youngsters Yemen
read the history a lot of rappers made
[ __ ] up
like that they came from a different
place than they actually came from
because if you weren't like hood and if
you weren't [ __ ] hard you had no shot
now the fact that all of you could just
like legitimately be who you want to be
like that's what everything [ __ ]
completely collided into each other all
the different cultures that I grew up
with and definitely the people before me
that were separate all that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] just colliding into each other
in fashion in the music and the food and
the way we roll and that's such a
positive that's incredible what the
interaction and the intersection is and
so I'm just watching it and it's super
interesting to me and I think the
biggest thing that I want to get out of
this talk is to encourage you to take
chances too many of you playing it safe
too many are worried about what other
people think
and what people are gonna think what
your crews gonna think and you've got
ideas like I sit here and look at all of
you I could just see the ideas you got
thoughts you got ideas you have
intuition of what would work if you're
asking me why me or other people have
one is we didn't give a [ __ ] what you
thought about our thoughts we just did
it and we [ __ ] let it play out
it's it this facts man like the people
that break through are the ones who just
had a little more courage they either
had what I had which is a mom that
[ __ ] puts so much self-esteem in me
that I just can't even think I'm not the
best in the world you know I can't she
just did it others came up a different
way had different reasons maybe you're
numb maybe you [ __ ] with the other
way got beat up so much you just [ __ ]
hit the bottom you're like [ __ ] it
like nothing else to lose right the
video I posted yesterday on Instagram
and the one I got like Andy it's like 20
million reach on Facebook when I talk
about just [ __ ] fail on purpose right
like watching all of you guys interact
with that like I kind of mean that it's
crazy for me that like I remember I'll
tell you a story I've never told
publicly I went to the White House
Barack Obama invited like seven people
to talk about like tech and
communication and like what the [ __ ] was
going on
I remember sat down I'm in the Oval
Office with Barack [ __ ] Obama right
and like the CMO of like Amex and Angela
who's now the CMO of Apple and like
these gangster marketing people and I
remember sitting there and I walked in
and I sat down and I'm sitting directly
I'm sitting like directly from Barack
Obama's the best part I called him
Barack and everybody corrected me like
mr. president like oh sorry should I
tell somebody's gonna shoot me um and
and actually in the slip of the way I
called him Barack that was the only
thing I thought about on the Acela on
the train back to New York the whole
time which is [ __ ] it I've been to the
tippy-top of a human being this the man
that runs [ __ ] period free world I felt
better and so that's what I want for
everybody just that feeling where no
matter where you are you just don't care
you really don't and I know that's hard
and honestly if you ask me what I'm
doing with my content right now I'm
trying to be your shield I'm trying to
make you jump and if you fail you just
point to me and be like Gary told me you
know like he's the reason I [ __ ] up he
tricked me he's a piece of [ __ ] I'm
sorry like I don't care what you do cuz
I know if you'll jump it's gonna feel a
lot better
cuz it's regret the reason I keep
telling you guys to go to a nursing home
is I want you to get face to face with
somebody who's not your grandparent that
has regret coming through their face and
that's what's happening in old person
homes they've regret telling you right
now they have regret like even if you
live like I feel already like I can go
now and I did good but I'll still have
tons of regret I'm like what if and
there's some [ __ ] I should've I could
have bought the Jets have I stayed alive
you know like like just random [ __ ] like
I'm trying to get people closer to
regret because when regrets
scares you when like you see regret like
a horror movie and it shakes you to your
core you bounce back the other way and
you start doing [ __ ] because you realize
how ridiculous it is that you're not
doing stuff cuz you're home you might
think it's stupid or because your older
brother had better grades than you or
cuz your mom told you you were never
gonna be anybody and so that's where I'm
at that's where my headspace is at
I'm trying to hack attention I'm trying
to understand and synthesize culture but
most of all it doesn't matter if you're
wearing a supreme backpack or some Yeezy
sneakers or this and that but the thing
that's true is like six seven things in
life all this other stuff is disguising
all the sub their stuff is like
fulfilling insecurities all this other
stuff is you expressing yourself to the
world of who you are most of you are
wearing everything you're wearing right
now as a quick quick interaction with
everybody else to try to tell everybody
who you are the way you wear your hair
man's wearing a cap hoodie right he's
trying to say something like that's what
we're doing and the hair that you've got
you know beautiful by the way and so
like we're trying to like say something
about who we are real quick
and that's why I love and [ __ ] with
fashion not like I don't love fashion
but I love what it does for us it helps
those of you who don't communicate like
I do communicate I just want to make
sure you're using it to communicate not
close some insecurities that you have
and you want to fit in and that's what I
love so much about what's happening now
is it feels like blank canvas feels like
you know what's crazy right now is if
you've got any kind of audience and you
got just a little bit of confidence you
can do anything if you take the hundred
people that have the most confidence
downstairs if they walked in here with
an umbrella as a hat in the first ten
minutes everybody be like what the [ __ ]
and an hour later people like will where
do I get that umbrella and I'm
fascinated by that and I implore you to
get into that mindset and so I feel like
anybody who's sitting here right now is
[ __ ] with me and I hope you
understand why you are because this is a
great era especially for the subculture
that's sitting here there's a lot of
minorities
brown and black and girls and I mean
minorities of not white male which I am
one of this is the greatest theory
because the Internet's the middleman and
nobody stopped my tea [ __ ] do you think
Harvey Weinstein and Kevin Spacey are
getting taken down and every by the way
if you're a bad person and you're 60
years old you're [ __ ] your pants
right now cuz you're [ __ ] next and
you know how happy I am about this do
you know how happy I am do you know how
happy I am that the girl sit in third
row in the middle Kate Franklin like
somebody who worked for me for a short
period of time that I know every
interaction I had with her I know what
she says behind my back I know why we're
gonna meet in the hour and talk again
like doing the right thing is always the
right thing and this is finally the era
where that's gonna play out because 20
50 people used to be able to hide [ __ ]
and so it's about to get much better or
much worse depending on how you decide
to live your life and so if you go read
my first two books crush it and thank
you economy very subtly and very
specifically I'm telling people the
shadows of our society are about to
change that I changed when I learned
social media like when I was in my head
when I was like [ __ ] everybody's gonna
know everything about everything
and so since 2008 I've just been living
a different kind of life you know and I
just like it I think the only way to
survive and really win is gonna be on
good and positivity and that's crazy
that's super exciting and so I implore
you to know one thing
everybody you know I laugh when people
like some of you are just mad and some
of your meta you know like I laugh when
I leave a situation quick selfie quick
lo quick love and I walk and I know
what's happening 9 out of 10 times are
like oh man thank God he's just nice and
personal I was hoping he wouldn't suck
you know like like it's always good and
I laugh because I find it funny that we
become so cynical because of the world
we've lived in for the last hundred
years that being nice or doing the right
thing is the positive outcome right that
it's not the expected then we're
protecting ourselves because we don't
want to be let down that even there's a
sit there's a saying like you don't want
to meet your heroes like it's so sad and
I don't think that's gonna
out the next hundred years and so most
of you were very young in your game
right
you're not even you you're thinking and
you're aspiring in your brain the way I
did when I was in this audience of where
you're gonna be but it's still five
seven 15 20 years away right I just want
to make sure that you realize the
quickest way because everybody wants to
get here quick
so ease patience the quickest way to
guarantee you'll get to where ever you
want to get to is by treating every
single person you interact with with
serious love cuz they will build you
they will build you they will put you on
your back and they're also the people
that will [ __ ] tear you down behind
you think you know you think somebody
who's in power in charge who's got some
juice is the one that you need to be
pairing pandering to those people aren't
doing anything for you it's the people
that you're sitting next to right now
kindness is gonna be the currency and
that is where we're going and it's
[ __ ] beautiful like it's real good
like everybody thinks shit's bad now let
me just tell all of you what's happening
in culture where we're spreading apart
and we're like an almost intellectual
civil war and everything that's going on
let me tell you what's going on and
remember that I said it this is just one
step backwards two steps forward we
needed to get exposed because we were
hiding under the makeup of the old media
landscape we needed to just come to
grips that we still got some [ __ ] to get
through and now that it is on like we're
in it the lights are on our differences
the lights are on our shortcomings I'm
happy cuz the way you go forward is
acknowledging and respecting what the
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up and so I'm very
optimistic I think the next five to ten
years are gonna suck the way it feels
like it's sucking now I still don't
think it's really sucking cuz you're in
control
you can dwell on what you can't control
or you can focus on what you can and so
I'm real excited I'm really excited I'm
really grateful that you guys are
spending 45 minutes of your time
with everything that's going on
downstairs here with me so thank you and
I
[ __ ] you sum up I went super heady and
like up here and emotional and like up
here but while we've got this twenty
five minutes this is the time to get
selfish as [ __ ] and let's go real down
here like aka yo how do I sell hats on
LinkedIn good job man
[Applause]
and I think I clarified it in one of the
last sessions where I was like look Oh
actually we haven't put it out it was
the one with a big crib right like I
clarify like it's if you've got it like
that put it out like that my big thing
is that Michael Jackson and Prince sat
on hundreds of songs we haven't heard
and so like do I to your point
quality quantity look what I'm doing I'm
putting out [ __ ] a ton of [ __ ] every
day and I have a good feeling because
I'm looking at every day you know that
it's quality right and so if you can put
out a hundred thirteen songs do that if
you can put out 365 do that because
these are at-bats musics interesting
musics like content you're literally one
song away my man you're literally like I
need you to really wrap your [ __ ]
head around what I'm about to tell you
15 years ago you had to get found you
had to get signed you had to get through
this you know people taught you know
when I talk about this a lot of artists
came
I made a reference to like you had a get
found by LA Reid and then put on and
some girl jumped in the comments on
instance she's like and even that
doesn't happen she's like I was signed
with it by LA [ __ ] Reid and I got
caught up in the system my [ __ ] never
even came out so 20 years ago man you
you had no [ __ ] chance
it was [ __ ] point zero zeros it was
ridiculous
now you you can put something on
soundcloud or spotify tomorrow and it
just might be the song so yeah i want
you to put out as much as you've got and
if you only got six good songs in you
then you're not gonna hear anyway right
and so or or maybe i'm wrong to you know
actually as i said it i'm taking a step
back one great song is a lot of people's
entire career right right so you know
let's not call people out and so yeah
man I just want you putting out stuff
right like you know I when I was in
Mount Ida college battle rap was real
hot and like people used to really go up
against each other
and some of this [ __ ] that I heard is
like the coolest best [ __ ] ever heard
and a week later I talked to him and
they don't even remember what they said
because they weren't writing and then
battling [ __ ] they were like really
doing it from the top that's why I'm
Darach man some of the best you know
that [ __ ] video with that little kid
in the liquor store whereas like told
him not to worry about YouTube views
they got so many views that would have
been lost in [ __ ] space back in the
day back in my day two years ago that
would have been lost in space but now
that I have them filming right like so
yeah man I think I think the quality
quantity conversation was for a day and
aged we're distribution was different
it's true but as many at-bats as you get
because what is crazy is one song and
sometimes it comes early lil yachty just
it happened fast right here's one song
happened quick you know Kylie fucking's
you know or you know just like you know
like one person puts it on you know you
got it
I mean hey Gary uh hired Duran host of
podcast junkies I have two pieces of
gratitude and a question the first is I
don't know if you remember Oh first
thank you for getting me in here for
free because this is on you and your
text message that I worked
so that's like I don't know if you
remember CJ bowling from vid such ones
give you a quick update here's that 30
followers on YouTube he's at 10,000 now
I just thought yesterday so kudos the
question is I'm more interested rather
than a tip or tactic to understand what
your OS is like so what's something
you've changed your mind about recently
well that's a great question what if I
do
God you know it's funny cuz I'm narrow
and deep changed my mind changed my mind
um I'll tell you know I don't have a
quick answer but I'll tell you the best
thing that I've changed my mind about
which I guess I changed my mind but it
was more my actions I've become much
better at radical candor at vaynermedia
I'm so positive and I like love honey
over vinegar that I think at times the
second time there was conflict or issue
where I decided to deploy more optimism
and more honey and more sunshine and
hoped when they went back out out of my
office into the company or my audience I
think that I'm starting to do a better
job of speeding up the process where I'm
like look you're [ __ ] up and you're
gonna get fired and let me tell you what
to do instead of making that the fourth
conversation it's now starting to be
closer to the 2.5 conversation and I've
got to be honest with you I've felt the
very positive ramifications of that and
has taken me from positive and good and
a little closer to shooting it straight
you know I talked about my dad that was
more about my actions and not stealing
and not doing the wrong thing and not
bullshitting but I think I'm going
through a weird version cuz Boehner is
getting big and I've almost a thousand
employees now and I've seen some of the
things I don't like about Vayner face to
face and it's on me the thing I've
changed my mind about is when I think
about the honey Empire and honey over
vinegar
I used to say honey over vinegar but I
think in my actions I was honey honey
honey honey honey over vinegar or even
worse the thing I'm most fearful of
honey honey honey honey honey you're
fired and if you were the kind of person
that wasn't self-aware if you didn't
hear the vinegar even though I was
trying to tell you in every piece of
honey like you're [ __ ] up shit's not
right it still felt like I [ __ ]
pulled the rug out from underneath you
so I would say the the adopt ants of
radical candor in the mix of my tool
belt in my Swiss Army knife
it's taking me to the next level and I
imagine they appreciate you more in the
end because you're honest with them
asure you know it's funny a certain
group that 25% that was my vulnerability
no question is probably gonna appreciate
it more and at least if nothing else
they're not stunned even though for me
it was like how did you not see it in
the nuances now it's just more black and
white sewed opting a little more black
and white thank you you got it Gary
what's up man Ivan good to see you again
great to see you Ivan so my wife and I
just started running a YouTube channel
it's probably not for the demographic
here it's ballet videos for young
children for parents and stuff like that
don't sleep on people's ballets
obsessions up in here yeah so we produce
video they're expensive to make but
that's not an issue we're giving content
giving content why are they expensive to
make just costing to rent out studio
editor's green screen making it look
professional all that stuff do you one
thing I'm gonna press on is just give
thought if you're going to professional
given the reality of where you're at so
the money thing isn't an issue okay you
know respect it's fine so we're giving
out content all the time we're not sure
we thought about either reaching out to
brands and getting sponsorships you know
tactic like the backpack kid we thought
about maybe we created our own ballet
shoe and sell merchandise what if we're
not sure we're giving we're not sure
what that ask is or if there even is an
ask I mean I think you're in the best
[ __ ] spot ever then like you know to
me I never thought like I'm a
businessman and an entrepreneur so I
never thought a casus Swiss sneaker was
gonna be the ask like like you know to
me it came things come to me so I think
that if you're in a place where you're
not sure then I wouldn't stress yourself
of coming up with one cuz if you force
it it's gonna fail mm-hmm it's not gonna
come natural from you they're gonna feel
it's not natural it's just gonna break I
would just tell you to keep building
leverage and attention because when you
want to deploy it I mean this whole
thing like yeah I've got a sneaker and
I've got a book but these are
inexpensive things along the way for in
return for what I'm giving like I don't
want to ask at all so that I can ask for
my final ask which is if
let's go up for sale and I cut a couple
dollars short I think I'm gonna crowd
fund it from the world
and and close the gap right and so I
don't think you have to force yourself
into and ask and I think you need to
stay curious and open to see if it comes
to you but I don't think you have to
force it if you could afford to and if
you get to a place where you can't
afford to give yourself six good months
and that might be right now if you feel
like okay but in six months we're gonna
be forced to doing something and start
being real thoughtful and but it's much
better if it comes naturally to you cool
I like the six month thing and that's
very practical and yeah like you said we
don't want to do that like we can easily
do like a $1.99 per month subscription
but I feel like those are just so it's
it's everyone's doing it and we don't
want to just be the man let me tell you
something right now and for all of you
mmm you will never succeed if you sell
something you don't believe in so many
of you are selling something because it
seems like it's the thing that sells and
you will lose 100 percent you got to
stand by your product you got to love at
first so I get that hoodies right and
beanies and sneakers and backpacks feel
right now but if you love your [ __ ] it
will come to you in three years
nobody who's wearing socks that had cool
[ __ ] on it five years ago right so like
if you really believe in it and you love
it it will come to you and things go up
and down things go up and down yeah
don't force it but if you know you need
it in six months and I saw how you
reacted start getting curious and start
really getting deep in ballet culture
and maybe in the depths of ballet
culture on some small hashtag you see
somebody doing something fly and you're
like okay that's gonna emerge maybe DMM
you want to do it together
or maybe you're inspired by it and DJ
your own version of it cool cool can I
get a right hook real quick mm-hmm for
those with young children out there
Buttercup ballet on YouTube good for you
thanks Gary you got it hey guys just
real quick I hate to be this guy but we
have time for five more questions if we
make them quick please you got it and if
you're in line I'll try to make six if I
go real quick go I'll be quick yo what's
up Chum
bless up you an amazing person I met you
back at a shoe palace
yes that was an amazing day because when
I looked at the vlog after you posted I
was like skimming through skimming
through about like 18 minutes of that
[ __ ] was just like not shoe palace and
then it gets the shoe palace and I was
the guy that you you put the clip in it
was a foot and it's so funny because I
was at an event on Friday supporting a
friend and someone some random person
was like yo gary vee post a video with
you i thought that was like the craziest
thing i don't have a specific question
to ask you because you give out so much
free content yep i just take it and i
apply it and i do trial and error and
every day what i do have to ask you
though is i want to challenge you to
rock paper scissors okay and if i beat
you
we have to sit down okay so i've only
done this one other time and it was with
Jerome Jarre yes and he won because he
cheated are you good at cheating - I'm
gonna tell the truth I'm good at winning
but are you good at it because you kind
of like actually like practice rock
paper scissors and you know I do and I
always play rock paper scissors for who
pays and no make your girl paper [ __ ] no
respect I get it listen whatever she
wants yeah all right yeah let's do it
cool all right what is it a 1 2 3 shoot
no no one this dude came up he was like
I'm not gonna take a lot of time now
we're doing this [ __ ] then he wants then
he won right right my man right then he
wants to out of [ __ ] three oh why why
not a 7-game serious one time ready is
it well I want to make sure so it won
rock-paper-scissors then shoot
got it Rock Paper Scissors shoot Rock
Paper Scissors shoot you got it
Gary at vaynermedia you're gonna say I
beat you rock-paper-scissors and I'm
gonna [ __ ] have a meeting with you
let's go what's up Zeus Zeus nice to
meet you
I just started a YouTube subscribers
good yeah and I honestly wanted to get
I'm trying to build up my Instagram as
well and yep I would like to get a audit
Instagram audit firm you okay maybe just
you DME and see what you think I can do
or what you think I should do okay
Andy's gonna do it for you because he's
smarter than me alright done I kind of
want to play him paper-rock-scissors
just when you take his spot well you see
if he keeps up his spot I'm gonna move
we [ __ ] it hey how are you my name is
Omar we met in a Washington Square Park
back me yes that was a fun night
yeah I remember you actually what's up
man oh thank you so my question is uh
you always talk about how difficult
client services is yes so I just don't
want to know like what was that first
conversation like when you're getting
that first client for $40,000 yes and
also I understand kind of the long-term
vision of vaynermedia yes so how do you
see it moving from essentially the
client service marketing machine does it
become private equity receive number two
I'm building up my management team my
winners so that one day just on
intuition I'll feel like it's ready for
me not to be there then I'll spend
another six months my intuition my guess
right now is three years from now I'll
spend another six months tying up all
the loose ends and in that same six
months I'll start really looking for
brands you know the cake you know Barney
did such a mitzvah for me you know I'm
so excited because I want case what I
mean I'm like focused on this right like
the plans we have for next year like the
way I'm thinking about the threes and
fours like I really want k-swiss
to completely I mean for the people that
are really understanding like I don't
think people really understand like
k-swiss is like spot in hip hop culture
back in the day like real [ __ ] like
ice-t like real like really so I think
you know I'm excited cuz I'm giving it
my all I want them to win way more than
what they compensate but for me this is
a nice little middle test case for like
rejuvenating brands cuz that's what I'm
thinking about so that's how I'm
thinking about it
as far as as far as the first part you
just gotta ask like if you're asking for
yourself like getting clients is that
where you going no not you're just
curious yeah I just asked I just you
know people are emailing me up about
Wine Library I knew vaynermedia was
coming I just would look at their
signature and their email and be like
hey I'm starting a marketing company the
way I built this Wine Library do you
want to be my client yeah I don't think
people understand the game of asking
right I never say no for the other
person never say no for the other person
the man last thing yes just kind of some
time I mentioned before yes I'm a senior
in college obviously like I was doing
the whole Wall Street thing yeah at
Goldman Sachs
yes but I'm actively kind of trying to
segue into vaynermedia so I just want to
say hopefully maybe I'll see you next
few months or so I hope so man pleasure
hi sure hi Gary oh my god how do you do
the five-second rule to come here okay
first of all thank you I'm so grateful
to be here and thank you to my boyfriend
and inspirational artist Lois King oh
you are so the main reason I'm here well
I am in the health and fitness industry
and I've had my own business and my
nutrition center running for four years
and I love it but I just find so much
more passion in singing and writing yeah
the crazy thing is I am like trying to
balance everything and like I wake up at
5:00 a.m. I go to sleep at 11:00 12:00
1:00 a.m. okay you know so I'm like
trying to balance everything out social
media is working out I just started up
my youtube but I'm having a hard time
like staying consistent with building
content so I was just wondering like
should I just document yes struggle John
document yes
like how busy I am like this is why you
already know that's why I used the word
document you know that was the biggest
breakthrough for me for my audience in
the last three years the documenting
versus creating like if you just Doc
guys we're interested in each other I'm
interested in your struggle I'm
interested in what your favorite
fast-food places I'm interested in like
you know are you a Laker fan like like
people are just interested in [ __ ] yeah
and the crazy thing is like I'm also
like really involved in the whole
motivational thing because of my past of
drug abuse and gang violence and whatnot
and being an entrepreneur now so it's
saying I tell you what's holding you up
yeah and all of you you hear me you just
don't want to accept the [ __ ]
patients part
yeah you were young you make you make
like people people that are Barney how
old are you Barney's 45 and he's young
as [ __ ] right right like he just is he's
got 30 [ __ ] get more years in the
game like do you know how long 30 years
is right like what's [ __ ] you up
right now is what's [ __ ] them all up
you hear me you're like yo guarantee
patience yeah but you don't live it you
don't live it like I do yeah
like like like I lived it and I'm still
living it like do you know where I'm
gonna end up right the tippy [ __ ] top
you know where I'm now upper-middle so
I'm patient I'm grinding I'm here I'm
hustling down there I'm [ __ ] hustling
a patient for what are mine like it you
know final stop is gonna be your just
not patient like if you're feeling any
angst it's cuz you don't love the
process more than the results you're
thinking about $10,000 a month an
Adsense instead of loving the [ __ ]
dirt and loving this grind moment and
the second you fall in love with the
grind for real 19 years of it not a
month when you [ __ ] really fall in
love with the grind and sit here how old
are you my man how old are you I know
that's inappropriate any seven 19 years
if you're like cool I'd [ __ ] you know
46 it's gonna get going
if you've a knew how young Barty how
young do you feel young if you knew what
46 felt like 19 years wouldn't scare you
right right now it does
cuz it's more it's almost your whole
[ __ ] life that's it okay patience at
it don't like do if you're really
grinding 5 to 11 yeah well then you're
[ __ ] doing the work now the next part
is patience and then your talent is
gonna take you where it's gonna take you
like either you got it or you don't I do
and like if you do you have it to some
level and somewhere between Beyonce and
sh me on say is where you're gonna end
up right and you just as long as you're
putting in the grind and having the
hustle you just got to respect that
somewhere being up between B
saying SH Mian say right or you're
picking the wrong thing and your
romantic about music but you're the best
architect that ever lived but you never
tried it that's the framework if you're
working as hard as you can and you're
patient then your talent is gonna take
you to where it is right or did you pick
the wrong thing listen I wish I could be
a rapper but I just know I'm not and I
know I've got rapper tendencies in the
way that I talk but I'm an entrepreneur
I will [ __ ] build a bigger business
and all of you combined every day of the
week that's the [ __ ] facts and that's
it take it for what it is and if that
motivates you show me email me in 15
years with this clip show me thank you
so much this is our last question guys
my man my name is South Florida off the
RIP I just want to tell you thank you so
much for inspiring all of us I've gone
through some difficulties in the past
couple years and your words have really
got me there's some struggles and
everything and my question for you is
I've gone through probably 15 surgeries
physical therapies here in there and I'm
trying to piece all the documentation
together and try to make an impact to
others by sharing them my positivity
that nothing's ever hold me back I was
down yeah and I was gonna see what
someone from your stature from someone
who's made it in the industry someone
who's trying to become up and coming how
to get there how do I get how do you get
to the next spot yes you know it's gonna
be the repeat of the last thing and the
truth is you know your circumstance
matters so [ __ ] much because it's one
thing if you've got less adversity in
your life regardless of what it is for
everybody else in this room who's not in
a machine right now right and if you're
in the negative mindset it's a whole
different thing to the audience that
sees themselves in you it's real easy to
get dark it's real easy to not see it
right so it's gonna be patience and
things of that nature right it's gonna
be the same stuff and it's gonna be the
stuff that I started with which is how
so back to what you were saying because
I want to take my last two minutes with
you okay how are you putting out your
content
Oh through Instagram and snapchat it's
an I haven't really executed anything
I've kind of have a very variety large
base back at home in South Florida and
everyone kind of knows who I am in my
home city in high school and might call
it take one too so everyone's kind of
known who I am and I've always kind of
been uplifted I've never been held back
never looked at anything I he'll I
travel 3,000 miles in California see you
with my buddy so everything kind of
doesn't hold me back so what I just
having struck struggles kind of getting
the Queen you want to happen like no no
no [ __ ] wanna like from a Fame and
financial I don't want any financial out
on anything I want people to read that
I'm 4 foot for 22 years old 1 through 15
surgeries and born with dwarfism that
I'm at complex Constanta Monica and I
didn't let anything any [ __ ] hold me
back well good news hopefully be rocks
been filming somebody's been filming
we'll definitely make sure that happens
to some small degree let me give you a
good piece of advice you need to get
somebody who does what the rock and
babban do and you just start vlogging
and somebody filming you and I'll help
you get somebody for free for a year
got it got it I'm bow way not because I
like real quick not cuz I'm gonna pay
I'm not that great of a guy I mean it
it's because there's so many amazing
creators who'd want to do it and they're
gonna know that I care and if they do it
for him for a year then I will do
something I don't know what that's
number one number two you're gonna make
it a facebook watch shell so everybody's
trying to blast off on YouTube and it's
hard cuz supply and demand of attention
there's a lot of [ __ ] on YouTube and
there's not a lot of growth hacking ways
to get there collaborations there's some
stuff thumbnails titles but it's a
[ __ ] grind even for us we haven't
Clark you know popped it Facebook watch
for all of you right now I'm telling you
right now I'm so happy I haven't said
this really publicly yet Facebook watch
is a huge opportunity here's why
facebook wants to kill YouTube cos sucks
is a gangster okay I know he doesn't
look like it but take every gangster
downstairs combined and they don't have
[ __ ] on one little sucks dude as a
[ __ ] gangster
so here's what Facebook's doing if you
make a watch show and if you don't know
what I mean when I say Facebook watch
news alert Google what is Facebook watch
read it understand it start your vlog on
Facebook watch not on YouTube because
facebook wants Facebook watch to work
right so they're gonna give you extra
distribution even though you got nobody
take your facebook fanpage take your
insta take your snap take your YouTube
take the signature in your email and
push everything into your Facebook watch
call 36 of your homies and be like yo it
would just mean the [ __ ] world to me
if you subscribe to my Facebook watch
and the first one that comes out just
share it and like it got it just [ __ ]
you know like I always talk about this
is why I love this culture it's just
mixtapes from the back of your [ __ ]
hoopty you know it's just the baseball
card show like I got goose bumps all up
in my body when I walk down there like
this a baseball card show right it was
how I grew it was selling blow pops out
of my backpack you know that's all this
is it's the same [ __ ] it's just with
attention and the stakes are bigger
Facebook watch flog get everybody in
your high school in college at anybody
that ever gave a [ __ ] about you take two
straight days and just [ __ ] lounge
you'd be like this link follow me on
this show when I would a new book coming
out like I'm crushing a come out in
January like door my holiday vacation in
this winter I will lay there and hit up
every person one by one not both blast
email not an Instagram story one by one
by one and be like yo buy my book and so
everybody here can do that for whatever
the [ __ ] they want get-get 813 people to
follow your watch show get all of them
on the first episode you gotta text them
back again reel grinding 15 hours a day
bizdev exciting into the DMS hitting up
everybody right you get a thousand
people to like and share your first
episode of a Facebook watch blog write
and share it something will happen mark
mark mark my words you're welcome so
much
1:30 1:30 to 3:30 I will be at the case
Wis booth come through buy a pair or not
take a picture or not hug it out
or not but I appreciate all of you have
a good day love it hope you enjoyed that
would love to get your 3 cents not 3
cents in the comment section on two
things 1 what was the best beverage you
had during Thanksgiving and - what was
the unique new insight from this keynote
that caught your attention see ya
[Music]